I had a problem with this guy we were
texting back and forth and he stopped
replying to me he never sent me a threat
which is quite interesting and then
about four days later I was walking to
my car in a car park late at night
typical English weather it was a little
bit wet dark and I heard footsteps
coming fast and as I turned
it's a struggle reading the Quran daily
before you instructed instructed me to
download this app I never knew that this
app would have such an impact on
people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah I came
across a video of our brother Andrew
Tate Miller keeping firm inshallah in
his religion and increase him in
knowledge he's sitting down and he seems
very calm he seems like he's safe and he
talks about his fears what is his
greatest fears and he mentions how he
feels more safe where he is because
behind him is a vast amount of you know
space and he's got security guards he's
innate cross parameters uh defense like
in any fortified Place candle no we're
not gonna say 45 Castle but there's
something that our brother Andrew say is
missing and that is
intentionally doing this but maybe he
doesn't know about it this video is
specifically for him before we get into
that let's watch the video and
understand what are the concerns that
brother Andrew Tate has and how we can
connect this to Islam and the Beautiful
Solutions Islam offers which is a peace
of mind but here I am with empty space
behind me and I can relax it's a
beautiful thing I don't sit in chairs
unless the chair is to the back I can't
sit in a room a restaurant with my back
to people because no matter how good you
are somebody wants you dead and there's
people walking past you all the time 100
people walk past you one of them decides
to stab you are you ready to detect it
probably no I had a problem with this
guy we were texting back and forth and
he stopped replying to me he never sent
me a threat which is quite interesting
and then about four days later I was
walking to my car in a car park late at
night typical English weather it was a
little bit wet dark and I heard
footsteps coming fast and as I turned
see the footsteps was he attempted to
stab me and that's why everyone knows he
well knows that my finger basically came
off where I put the hand took the knife
instead of my neck it's kind of like
people often say to me Andrew you know
you have all this money what's the most
expensive thing you've got the true most
expensive things in the world are one
piece of mind and two time peace of mind
is also something else that's very
expensive and it's worth so much money I
will pay unlimited money for private
security I'll pay unlimited money to
make sure I have the table in the corner
with my back to the wall I will pay
anything it takes to have peace of mind
I'll tell you something when I'm in
London I'm getting a haircut I hire out
the entire barber shop I can't sit in
that chair knowing the door's unlocked
with a towel over my face knowing that
someone can walk in that shop and stab
me or that one of the other people that
want me I can't do it I buy the shop for
an hour close lock the door close the
showers cut my hair and I leave and I
have two guards outside because peace of
mind is invaluable so guys very very
interesting points so one thing that we
need to mention Brown assistant is that
when it comes to these kind of things as
human beings we usually take the aqual
our logic over the text usually we tend
to fall for the solo and this is one of
the demises of shaytan because he took
his logic over what God commanded him
and he fell into disbelief so what does
this mean most of the times brother and
sisters when we go through certain
traumas in our life we tend to be more
cautious this is natural human nature
however this sometimes goes to levels
and points where I've seen people become
an obsessed as if if they are not in
control they feel in fear it's as if
they need to be in control like
sometimes I have this as well when I'm
on a plane I am not secure because I
don't necessarily trust a pilot I mean
people does a better job than me but the
fact that I am not in control is an
issue of a lack of tobacco so we all
have this some one way or another but
there are ways of dealing with this so a
message to brother Andrew yes you went
through this trauma where someone tried
to you know take your life and after
that you know you don't like sitting in
places where you can't see behind you
you know you've even mentioned another
video where you would have close friends
that you trust that can keep an eye
behind you you sit um near walls you
know there's your back is against the
wall you you have to security you hire
out the whole Barber Shop Etc somebody
all understandable and we know that the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him told
us that you should tie your camel there
was a man who's going to the mosque in
his time and he left his camera untied
and the prophet saws said to him why did
you not tie a camel he said I trust I
put my trust in Allah which is a I want
to say another extreme but the process
and told us look you tie the camel and
then you put your trust in Allah so you
don't jump from a 10-4 story building
and say oh I'll put my trust in Allah
you're gonna you're gonna die I'm trying
to say so there's a fine balance but we
should have tawakulun Allah what does
that mean that means our trust like we
talked about peace of mind now this is
one of the concepts I had in Islam when
it comes to coming when I came to Islam
knowing my wealth knowing my health is
protected by God Almighty and what he
deems that's going to happen is going to
happen that gave me a peace of mind that
I don't care if I open a business and
I'm selling arguments here I don't let's
be stereotypical here let me sell them
I'm doing don't give up yeah and 10
other Kebab shops open next to me I
would not give a damn you know why
because I know what's going to reach me
is going to reach me I was not going to
reach me is not going to reach me it's
as simple as that if someone intends to
harm me they would harm me even if
they're in on the other side of the
planet and if somebody if Allah willed
that this person can harm me even if
he's on an inch distance away from me he
would not be able to harm me this is our
belief my dear brother Andrew and what's
really important here is also that if we
look into the Quran Allah talks about
Allah says wherever you may be death
will overcome you even if you are in
fortified Towers when something good
before them they say this is from Allah
but when something even before them they
say this is from you say o Prophet both
of them destined by Allah so what is the
matter with you okay and another eye in
the Quran Allah says this is enjoined
onward on Whoever has faith in Allah in
the last day and whoever fears Allah
who's mindful Allah he Allah will give
him a way out from places he would never
have fought so God Almighty if you fear
me I will give you a way out from pieces
places you've never fought yeah and
another verse which we know is that
Allah says every social taste death and
you will be giving your full composite
conversation on the day of Resurrection
so we are going to die regardless now we
can do our best to protect ourselves but
just to give you a reminder my brother
Andrew Tate you can have security and
many other people you can have security
armed guards bulletproof vest you know
you can be in a fortified castle like
Allah says if Allah wants you to die or
want any of us to die he will send a be
it an insect or guess what your heart
attack you will die in the very the
chair that you're sitting in and again
it's not too you're gonna it's not to
make you feel like to be scared the
point I'm trying to say is that you
should do your bit you should
acknowledge number one that every soul
is going to taste deaf 100 understood we
all accept that and that even if I'm in
45 castles if God Almighty determines
that I'm going to die I am going to die
so that's the one another thing we need
to also acknowledge to have trust in
Allah that he is our protector now one
thing that I'll recommend you my dear
brother Andrew is that um this app this
app is called up yeah by the way it's
not mine I'm not doing marketing
promotion yet this I've had do my
morning and evening is like the rest
Notre station the remembrance that you
do that protects you from all kinds of
hobby black magic because we believe yes
you might believe in physical harm but
Andrew say you're a Muslim now we also
believe in the Unseen World the Satan is
an enemy Allah is an enemy and take him
as an enemy just the way you are the way
your place gives you comfort and all
this kind of stuff because you've got
security guards and all that kind of
stuff you need to take the same
precautions to Satan iblies you know why
because he's in the Unseen we physically
see things like okay that guy you know
he might be carrying something Satan is
lurking the prophet sallam said Satan
runs through the veins of Adam yeah the
point is what we need to take
precautions against him more because
he's our biggest enemy he wants us in
the Hellfire the enemy that wants to
harm you he wants you your body to die
he wants to take your soul yeah he wants
to take your life yeah but at least
wants your soul and your soul is the one
that's the thing that's going to ever
lift the body's going to Decay but your
soul is going to be ever living yeah so
the point is what you should take that
more serious so if he's an enemy and
take him as an enemy your relationship
with the Quran wanting it even a car you
do it before no after assar before
Maghrib and you do it after Fajr this
protects you from evil evil eye black
magic and any physical harm except what
Allah has willed meaning you do your
best you do a card you read it Etc you
get your bodyguards that's fine you do
all of that and then you put your trust
in Allah not yourself not I've got these
things no no no no if Allah Wills I will
die but if he doesn't nobody can touch
me once you have this and I'm not saying
you have it or not if you do the beauty
of Iman your faith will be more solid
and you'll have more peace of heart not
thinking that everything you control is
what protects you may Allah bless you
guys